joh how do you describe the emotions of
just the entire day first game in eight
months you guys get down big and then
you kind of will them back in the second
half and hit the game with I mean I
imagine it's got to be as much of a
roller coaster as it gets uh emotionally
I know it wasn't you know too hard for
me um obviously you know I've been
prepping for this for you
know almost eight months you know it's
been eight months since I you know
played a game um I'm confident you know
in the work I was putting in and you
know trying to be in the best shape
possible to go out there and you know be
able to you know be out there for the
guys um as far as the you know going
down early I kind of expected it not to
be down you know like 20 whatever but um
I could I kind of expected to be like
some you know Jitters you know guys not
knowing what to do obviously I haven't
been out there for 25 games you know
they had a you know style of play uh
they had to you know adapt to you know
without me on the floor and you know me
coming in obviously you know I don't
want to you know change nothing up but I
also have to B J and uh I felt like you
know in that first half I was just kind
of you know trying to figure out you
know the game and then you know second
half I pretty much in locker room just
told the team you know stay together um
that we can make a run and you know
normally when you know that happens when
you have a big lead it's hard to keep it
in the NBA it's a game of runs U
especially you know with us being on the
road that's the extra chip you know we
have to play with we got to bring a lot
of toughness and energy and pretty much
said we was good and you know it showed
you know in the game once we got going
got some stops our offense started
clicking and we was able to come out
with a win uh yeah kind of following up
just what was the fatigue Factor like
for you today and then when you kind of
get into that fourth quarter mode not
just the the game winner but like that
last two minutes um do you even feel any
of that down the stretch uh for sure um
I had conversation with Dez you know
like asking him you know like what he
want to run you know late in those
situations I think I made like two
layups back to back before the game
winner and you know when I was going to
take off and come down down I felt like
my cast was about to start cramping um
that timeout we had to draw the last
playup I actually had um massage gun you
know my cal um I told Dez asking him you
know do we want to you know get a easy
bucket you know jiren pretty much you
know had a you know smaller defender on
them should we just you know go on the
post you know at the
time he told me no you getting the ball
so so at that point it's just you know I
pretty much just had to you know lock in
and go deliver um and I did so that's
good